we all know how the Second World War
ended with the decision to drop the
atomic bomb on Hiroshima on August the
6th as well as on Nagasaki on August the
9th whilst much is known about the
decision to drop the bomb on Hiroshima
not a great deal is said about the
conditions in the city in the immediate
aftermath of the bombing the bomb was
dropped at 8:15 in the morning about
70,000 people were killed near instantly
with about 10,000 more dying after fire
swept through the city so in the wake of
the atomic bombing the central Japanese
government didn't know what had happened
the US Air Force had been conducting
bombing runs over Japan continuously for
mumps by this point and the alarm wasn't
really sounded until the army garrison
as Hiroshima stopped reporting in after
many hours of not being able to get a
response army chiefs opted to send a
recon plane to see what has happened the
recon pilot saw the mushroom cloud from
over a hundred miles away but before he
could return to Tokyo to say what has
happened President Truman had announced
the bombing to the world unsurprisingly
the Japanese government was completely
unprepared for this event in early
rescue efforts were poor in fact the
first people the government sent there
were atomic scientists to determine
whether or not the Americans were lying
so the humanitarian response in the city
was pretty awful and the reason why was
that the death toll included many of the
city's high ranking officials as well as
medical and military personnel that in
the fact that the building where rescue
efforts were supposed to be coordinated
from no longer existed most of the city
civilian survivors fled to the
surrounding countryside were
infrastructure in the availability of
food and medical supplies was extremely
poor perhaps the most famous man to flee
the city was to Tomi Yamaguchi who after
suffering serious burns decided to seek
safety in his hometown of Nagasaki he
survived both atomic bombings Hiroshima
and relief efforts there were played
with supply issues there was little
drinking water food was sometimes scarce
and it took many weeks for medical
professionals to arrive on mass in fact
in the two hours after the blast the Red
Cross Hospital the largest one to
survive the blast had over 10,000 people
visit it had a capacity of 600 the man
who led relief efforts within the city
was a man called Shinzo Hawaii who
basically worked for weeks straight
attempting to fix infrastructure and
save as many people as possible his
initial efforts were undermined by the
fact that relief was organized through
the Japanese Army and given that they
intended to keep fighting the war
supplies and potential relief workers
were directed elsewhere and also in case
you're wondering the radiation
dissipated very quickly barring a few
areas of the city and so it
wasn't lethal to stay there the city
remained in its bleak state for about
two months when after the Japanese
surrender the city was occupied by the
American military an aide became much
more readily available you should also
know that the Americans pursued a policy
of heavy press censorship concerning the
after-effects of the bombings and thus
many in Japan were unaware of how bad
things were in Hiroshima so people
didn't really start to return to her
Ashima for a couple of years and most
settled in the outskirts of the city
in 1947 Hawaii became Hiroshima as first
democratically elected mayor and he
tried to work with the American
occupying forces to improve relations
the Japanese didn't start the process of
rebuilding the city proper until 1949
and it would be many more years until
the city recovered to its pre-war
population hiroshima and its people had
endured unimaginable tragedy and
remembering the stories of men like
Hawaiian Yamaguchi are important when
looking at the atomic bombings I hope
you enjoyed this episode and a special
thanks to all my patreon supporters
James vis annette marvin castle a man of
culture kelly moneymaker
Danny Maloney John bisque is Rob
Waterhouse mo Aaron the white James
Castaneda Gustav Swan Jordan long Rey
Marcus Ozma spinning three plates
cooling Castleman filled oink-oink
Rashid Ali David Silverman
easy Maggie packs Kowski Spencer
Lightfoot of Winston K word Robert
Wetzel Lexy Schwinn Anthony Beckett and
Skye Chappell